y como bien mencionabas 14 países además
del reino unido tiene nada
ahora el rey carlos tercero como como
jefe de estado y más de 50 países de la
commonwealth o la mancomunidad de
naciones y también la tiene como una
figura referente
qué puede pasar bueno
nos queda ver cómo construye carlos
ahora su reinado bajo bajo qué premisas
o qué prioridades
por las por las prioridades o las
premisas que tuvo durante estos años
se esperaría quizás que tuvieron un
reinado también un poco más enfocado en
el desarrollo en el juventud en el medio
ambiente pero pero claramente para dar
una figura de tamaña magnitud una
institución en sí misma no solamente la
monarquía sino la propia reiniciada el
segundo es una institución y ha sido una
institución en sí misma la monarca que
más ha reinado en la historia del reino
unido- y la segunda monarca que más ha
reinado en la historia de europa luego
de louis 14 de francia por lo tanto
claro claramente va a haber cierta
disrupción entre la relación del reino
unido- y la mancomunidad de naciones
y carlos el rey carlos tercero ahora
deberán renovar esta relación y rafael
sanz da abajo bajo otras otras premisas
quizás u otras prioridades de reinado
por lo pronto tenemos
las instancias más protocolares e
institucionales de renovar billetes
en el reino unido a cambiar la letra del
himno
las iniciales de los buzones de correo
en los pasaportes
y todo también un protocolo
institucional que decía bueno a cambiar
de monarca claro y además este cambio de
monarca también tiene una implicación
directa en las relaciones
internacionales de reino unido hablemos
concretamente de canadá australia y
nueva zelanda que hacen parte de la
mancomunidad y que tenían una estrecha
relación con la reina pero puede pasar
lo mismo ahora que el rey carlos tercero
será el rey o que pasa ante la ausencia
hablemos por ejemplo de las intenciones
de convertirse en república que tiene
australia
ahí hay algunos movimientos
buscan la la
la elección de una de una república
especialmente en australia en los
últimos años que pueden llegar a ser
revitalizados ahora que la reina isabel
ya no está y que tenemos al revisar los
terceros podría llegar a darse una
revitalización de estos movimientos por
lo tanto también acá será clave del rol
del nuevo rey y si elige visitar esos
países como sus primeros viajes
oficiales y como toma como enfoque a esa
relación del reino unido con aquellas
con países partes de la mancomunidade
naciones con los que tiene quizás una
relación también más estrecha y más
estratégica como lo son canadá australia
nueva zelanda
yo creo que quedará cambiado mucho en la
habilidad y en las personalidades del
rey y cómo maneja esas esas potenciales
focos de
si vemos esos movimientos de
republicanismo dentro dentro de
estos países y esa habilidad y esa
personalidad que usted menciona también
deberán ser utilizadas para unificar al
reino unido- y valga la redundancia y
por eso en los próximos días el rey de
carlos tercero va a viajar a irlanda del
norte a escocia y hágales que debe
mostrar el rey para lograr esa
unificación sobre todo luego de los
intentos de referendos independentistas
en escocia
sí exactamente como el monarca del reino
unido no solamente eso es quizás es algo
que también se suele ver en los medios
que es la reina de inglaterra o el rey
de inglaterra este es el rey del reino
unido que está conformado por cuatro
países e inglaterra gales escocia e
irlanda del norte por lo tanto carlos al
revisar los tercero deberá ser luego
viajes oficiales a las cuatro capitales
y también entablar relación no solamente
con disfraz que está el nuevo primer
ministro del reino unido sino también
con los primeros ministros de escocia
legales y de nueva
irlanda del norte
y bueno será también clave pensar como
como carlos va a designar para delinear
su reinado en relación con los países
que conforman el reino unido y con estos
gobiernos que son los gobiernos de
evolución de gales irlanda del norte y
gales
yo creo que también tiene cierto
simbolismo el hecho de que
bueno ahora esta semana va a haber
una ceremonia para la reina en el
palacio de hollywood y en la iglesia de
saint gilles en edimburgo que
parte de estas estas conmemoraciones se
van a dar en escocia primero antes que
en londres por lo tanto ahí también
puede haber cierto
potencial de unión entre entre el reino
unido que ciertamente este segmento va a
ser un elemento catalizador de unión
y luego quedará en el nuevo rey como
como encara esta relación